hey friends so I've got a story to share
back in 2013 Keith Marshall was halfway
through his tour of the United States
flow festivals and he built up quite a
following his three po technique
including the first po juggling I can
recall seeing won over a lot of
admiration he got a lot of people
excited not just for the possibility of
learning new tricks but also the
possibilities of merging together the
worlds of pois spinning and juggling we
were at ignite Festival in Joshua Tree
California and the heat had been so
intense that a small group of us piled
into the flow toys Van and went to a
local bar to get lunch and more
importantly access to an air conditioner
while we were there I voiced a couple
concerns I'd had about the idea of the
PO and juggling worlds merging while the
excitement many of the young Tech
Spinners had for the possibility was
palpable there were some aspects of that
merger that had me a little worried I
could already see shifts in the culture
around po to help fit it into the
juggling box that I found troubling one
of the other people at the table a
juggler jumped in and claimed that he
believed that the eological root of the
word juggle meant that it always was
supposed to refer to all forms of object
manipulation and spinning and I'll
confess that I was more than a little
confused the question was not over
whether indeed merging the POI and
juggling worlds was a good idea and what
cost that that might come at for po
Spinners but that such a question was
moot because Po's classification as a
type of juggling seemed self-evident to
him after all what use was there in
asking if po assimilating into the
juggling world was a good idea if indeed
you could just say that POI always had
been a type of juggling this was the
first time that a juggler and I talked
past each other on whether POI was or
should be part of the juggling world but
it was far from the last in the past 10
plus years I have had this same debate
in countless forms with countless people
that debate has been appearing a lot
more often lately and I think it's time
to really interrogate both the premises
that it's based upon and actually answer
the question my friend seem so Keen to
avoid is placing POI in the juggling
World actually beneficial to PO Spinners
Drex here from Drex Factor poy sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your brain and in
this video I am exploring one of the
biggest po questions of our era but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this Chann Channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca beonin thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission is Po and
or the flow Arts a part of juggling
that's a question that's led to more
than a few heated debates both in person
and online in the past decade I've had
this debate with friends strangers and
everyone in between representing
positions ranging from of course to
maybe no and well maybe they should be
so why is there even a debate and what
are the contentions on each side that's
what I'm going to dive into in this
video I'm going to do my best to present
the arguments in an objective fashion
but I'll be real with yall I do have my
own position on this and I'm going to
outline why that is one of the more
recent examples of this question coming
back up was when a meme got posted the
poy chat insinuating that it wasn't just
POI that is was and always had been
juggling but a variety of other movement
Arts including Rope Dart footag Color
Guard pen spinning and rhythmic
gymnastics too and I will confess that I
got a little heated in the uing comment
thread and a big part of the reason for
it is that it reflects an attitude I've
encountered a lot over the years from
jugglers like the one mentioned in my
opening story that I think both has
negative impacts on us as po Spinners as
well as reflecting badly on the juggling
World in general but why do jugglers
think this and why do some po Spinners
agree with them from what I can tell
there are three major lines of argument
and or motivations guiding it let's take
a look at each of
them part one can't we all get
along both the juggler from my story and
the person who posted the poy chat both
employ something I'll refer to as the a
priori argument for Po and flowarts
being a form of juggling a priori is a
Latin expression meaning from what is
earlier and it's a form of reasoning in
which a person employs deductive
reasoning based upon principles which
they believe are self-evident I've
encountered two variations on this sort
of a priori reasoning the most common
version of the first is as follows the
word juggle entered the English language
sometimes cir of the 14th century CE and
it is used to describe entertaining
Somebody by performing tricks thus
rather than being seen to Simply
describe the act of toss or contact
juggling people employing this argument
hold that the term should be understood
from its original context to be a
universal word that overlaps either
completely or nearly completely with the
related phrase object manipulation the
second is that regardless of its
etymology the word juggle in itself
should be understood to Simply Be the
word in English that conforms to a more
Universal platonic idea of using objects
to perform tricks we have evidence of
what we would recognize as toss juggling
going back more than 4,000 years with
the concept independently reinvented in
countless cultures across the world so
the 's an argument to be made that
juggling in itself is more or less
Universal to all human cultures and that
the word juggle is just the framing of
this concept in the English language the
thinking goes that juggling then is the
closest Universal concept to what we see
expressed with POI and thus the label
that should be applied to it I will
confess that I have some degree of
skepticism of both of these lines of
reasoning but I also believe they're
both ultimately irrelevant on a
practical level but more on that later
first let me explain my skepticism for
the a priori arguments I think the
biggest thing I'd touch on here is just
that I think we should be very careful
when we ascribe many Concepts as being
Universal to all human culture and
experience especially because a lot of
those conversations wind up getting
filtered through a Western European lens
whether intentional or not we sometimes
have a bad habit of taking our
particular framing of an otherwise
Universal concept applying our own
unique cultural baggage to it and just
assuming that our framing of that
concept is also universal one example
POI comes from kapahaka in maou culture
is kapahaka juggling then too is it
dance is it performance or is it
something that's outside of our cultural
understanding that is something we need
to learn more about mautic culture to
truly get a grasp on in trying to frame
kapahaka as dance we are in many ways
forcing it into a box that has a really
specific context here in the western
world and that context may not be
appropriate for how mauy people see
kapahaka we don't tend to think of dance
as being something one does to
intimidate one's enemies or something
one does as a mark of respect for a
person of high social standing to those
of us born in Western European
Traditions dance is seen as something
artistic frequently feminine and often
silly or frivolous thus in framing
kapahaka as a form of dance we may be
right that there are characteristics
that we associate with dance that is
moving rhythmically to a beat in an
aesthetically pleasing fashion but we're
also applying our specific cultural
baggage to the concept there may be a
human universality to moving to music
but that doesn't mean our framing of
that concept within our own culture is
universal too likewise while I think
it's safe to say that juggling is
something that either is or is close to
broadly Universal among human cultures
that doesn't mean that it is the
appropriate box to put every movement
art that involves performing tricks with
an inanimate object into because again
there's some really specific cultural
baggage that we in the Western European
tradition have that may not be
appropriate for how performing with
inanimate objects is seen in other
cultures and while I'm at it I also
specifically want to address the
linguistic argument because I also think
there are elements of it that are
ahistorical one of the biggest things we
have to recognize here is that language
is a living and evolving thing and the
context we think of for the word
juggling in our era is very different
from what it would have been for English
speakers of the 14th century for at
least the first couple centuries
juggling was understood to apply more
spe specifically to magic tricks in
slight of hand a connotation that it no
longer has the idea of it applying
specifically to what we see as juggling
today and more specifically toss
juggling wasn't even common until the
19th century and more to the point I
have yet to find a single Source within
the POI World whether Mau or Western
that refers to POI as juggling before
about the late 2000s or so granted POI
in general is so poorly documented and
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence but I do find the timing of that
shift interesting but I'll get more into
that later also if you have access to a
source from within the poy world that
does identify themselves as a juggler
from before that time period drop me a
comment and point me to where and no
jugglers saying PO is juggling doesn't
count I want to hear it from the people
actually doing the thing there's also a
second line of reasoning I frequently
see when it comes to placing POI and
flow Arts under the juggling umbrella
and it takes the form of comparing
what's going on in the United States to
the scene in Europe as I understand it
po has been considered a part of the
juggling and circus scene in most of
Europe now for many years indeed many of
the first generation of tech po Spinners
connected to each other through European
circus festivals and I'll be the first
to admit that my experience with the
Poise circus and juggling scene in
Europe and elsewhere in the world is
quite limited and it could well be that
all of these things live in Perfect
Harmony if so that's great for the
people who engage in the scene there but
I also kind of suspect that things might
be more complicated than that for a few
reasons the first is that when told that
POI and juggling are frequently framed
as separate here in the United States
the reaction I almost always see is that
the American approach to things is
somehow pathological there's not a lot
of curiosity as to why these identities
might be considered separate here
there's a kind of extension of that a
priori argument in that since that's the
way it's done in Europe that's the
default state of things and how it
should be done everywhere else in the
world and yeah remember our whole
discussion that a European framing of a
concept might not be Universal to all
human
culture and while I'll go more into
depth on this point later on I can't
help but notice that there's a poity of
representation for PO on the top 40
jugglers list as well as in the gala
Showcases of the European juggling
convention both of these are efforts led
by Europeans and there's not a lot of Po
representation there so I kind of
suspect if the integration of poi into
the juggling scene in Europe is kind of
a given that its integration there might
be superficial at best but jumping back
to the language argument for a moment I
will also admit that there's an
additional Dimension to that line of
reasoning that might indeed Circle us
back around in a different direction
language is indeed a living and evolving
thing and what different words mean
drifts over time so what if that's
what's happening right now the 19th
century definition of juggling was
certainly quite narrow and starting in
the 19 80s with the work of Michael moan
and the growth of cir nvo I think it can
be argued that artists who practiced
juggling were innovating upon many of
its tenants to grow the art form in ways
that probably would not have been
considered juggling by 19th century
artists British juggler Luke Burge
tackled this very question in an
exquisitely detailed video essay on the
definition of juggling noting that in
some ways juggling has evolved away from
describing a specific activity and has
come to mean an activity that someone
who considers themselves a juggler per
forms I agree with many of his
conclusions and I also can't help but
note that he ultimately rules out POI as
well as several of the other arts in the
PO chat meme laid claim to in the
process so why exactly would that
language be evolving Beyond simply the
new experiments of jugglers and into the
realm of trying to reframe other
movement Arts that haven't historically
been considered juggling and reclassify
them as juggling that takes us to what
I'd identify as the third and final
reasoning for placing POI and flow Arts
Under the Umbrella of juggling this is
what I'll refer to as the communal
argument the essence of this line of
reasoning is that we can Define juggling
not purely through eological or
philosophical means but as a byproduct
of the communities that come together
around and adjacent to it no one can
argue that the spaces jugglers inhabit
haven't also been inhabited by pois
Spinners rope artists and a host of
other types of prop manipulation and
flow Arts jugglers have frequently
though not always been present in spaces
I've inhabited as a pois spinner and
many have become friends and or inspired
me we can't deny that there are major
cultural overlaps here everything from
features at events targeting all these
groups to modes of dress the music they
listen to and a lot of the jargon that
they share I also have to point out that
buried within this line of reasoning is
something that I think goes a little
deeper than simply people inhabiting the
same spaces given that both poy and
juggling tend to appeal to people who
move in counterculture circles there's
also a degree to which this
reformulation of juggling as a concept
appeals to ideals of community inclusion
and cooperation there have been many
people with whom I've had this debate
who ultimately fall back onto a
sentiment that is some variation on I
just think we're a much stronger
Community when we're working together
jugglers see this as an invitation to be
included in a community they see it as
an act of benevolence but I don't let me
tell you
why part two setting the record straight
so now that I've spent a good amount of
time deconstructing all these different
arguments it is actually not a bad idea
for me to deal with the question on its
own merits should POI be considered a
form of juggling my answer to that
question would honestly be that it
depends upon the style of poy being
performed or used but by and large still
no many years ago I remember having a
remarkably candid conversation with a
juggler about why he didn't find POI a
particularly engaging form of prop
manipulation and I think his answer was
actually quite revealing he centered
that answer around one very important
concept risk a great deal of tossing and
balancing found in modern juggling
centers around creating moments of risk
that is moments when the trick could
fail and the prop could fall those
moments of risk guide an audience
through an experience that alternates
between tension and catharsis when a
juggler goes to perform a trick they
very literally have a bunch of balls in
the air we wait with baited breath to
see whether they will drop drop one or
more of their props but we are always
guaranteed a resolution either the
juggler will drop the prop and we will
have a moment of disappointment or they
will land their trick and we will have a
moment of euphoria in both cases though
we experience catharsis this cycle of
tension in catharsis around performing a
trick is broadly true of many other
circus Arts as well and I believe this
is why juggling has sat comfortably
beside acrobatics trapes and a variety
of other disciplines in this performance
tradition the only difference is the
scale of the risk ranging from dropping
a prop to genuine bodily harm this risk
is at the core of juggling as an art
form and having this relationship of
tension in catharsis remains a part of
it whether the performance venue is in a
three- ring circus a street performance
or in a video posted to social media but
as my juggler friend pointed out all of
those years ago POI does not have this
same relationship with its audience
arguably there is an element of risk
with POI overall given that we have to
keep the prop moving in order to avoid
having the tether go slack and return
our prop to rest but the consequences of
this happening aren't even the prop
landing on the ground they're simply the
prop hanging uselessly from the
performer's hand there is no catharsis
when a pyri goes wrong or when it goes
right rather than creating a
relationship of tension and catharsis
with the audience more often the words
that I hear used to describe highle po
spinning are things like mesmerizing or
captivating in other words most
classical POI and Tech POI centers more
around creating an experience for the
audience that just kind of Vibes giving
them a form of constant stimulation that
doesn't include the same Peaks and
valleys of juggling and this has both
positive and negative impacts on the
world of poi on the one hand one of
those things it's done for us has made
our art feel very accessible many of us
have had the experience of spinning and
breaking out some of our hardest tricks
and have a passer by stop to ask us if
they can try out the prop themselves to
a certain degree we work within a system
where the difference between very hard
and very easy petrix isn't super easy
for casual viewers to pick out and
though I don't know this for sure I
suspect it's comparatively rare for
jugglers doing five Club patterns to
find random passers by asking them to
borrow their clubs to work through their
own favorite Cascades and balances
juggling on its face presents a level of
difficulty that makes it feel less
immediately accept ible than po
frequently in po performances we've used
the addition of fire as a catalyst to
either add a degree of risk or to create
that heightened sense of tension that we
see in the juggling world but yet again
that tension exists in a more or less
constant state during the performance
rather than building and releasing
tension through risk like juggling does
and just to be clear there are
absolutely elements of juggling That
Just Vibe as well contact juggling in
particular includes several techniques
that lack the heightened tension that we
associate with toss juggling tricks and
fall more into the mesmerizing camp but
these techniques are the exception in
the juggling World rather than the rule
by the same token one of the chief
identifiers of manipulation as a style
within the PO world is a focus on
performing juggling techniques with POI
in these cases with POI juggling and
contact POI the element of risk is added
through the inclusion of those juggling
techniques but this is a subset of
stylistic techniques within poy rather
than the core set of techniques taught
for the prop now that may seem like kind
of an arbitrary or even overly semantic
way of framing Po in its relationship to
juggling but I actually think that
difference has some huge real world
implications that we should acknowledge
in any discussion around POI and its
relationship to the juggling
World part three the Trojan
Horse there is actually a really
powerful implication in what I outlined
in the last section and it goes to the
heart of a question that most arguments
class classifying po as a type of
juggling simply skip over namely is
being classified as a type of juggling
actually in our best interests as poy
Spinners something that I find very
curious about the a priori Arguments for
POI being juggling whether it be what
the original definition of the word
juggling was or whether there is a
platonic ideal of juggling that PO fits
into is that they kind of bypass this
question entirely how can we ask if
merging POI into the juggling world is a
good or a bad thing when it's
self-evident that PO is a form of
juggling after all I don't think that
this means of framing the conversation
to avoid that question is coincidental
at all in fact I think whether explicit
or not the very purpose of these apriori
arguments is to avoid engaging with that
very question because it's actually a
really sticky one in the last section as
I described my conversation years ago
with a juggler about po lacking the kind
of risk that I think is core to juggling
as an art and experience the person who
made this formulation was doing so
specifically because he wanted to
explain why he didn't find POI as
interesting and stimulating as juggling
and to be perfectly clear there's
nothing wrong with that not everybody
has to like the same things we can share
space ideas and interact as people even
if we don't share exactly the same
common interests but it does imply a
relationship that I find at least a
little bit troubling I think that this
juggler was right in that risk is indeed
something that jugglers expect to
encounter within the realm of prop
manipulation as well they should it's
core to the art they're interested in
practicing but when they don't encounter
that it appears to lead many to dismiss
forms of prop manipulation that don't
involve that element of risk as being
lesser forms of what they're framing is
juggling when we place juggling as the
platonic default of this idea that
overlaps with object manipulation in
several other disciplines we're also
creating a hierarchy in the process
juggling and more specifically toss
juggling is the Center of this world and
the standard by which all other forms of
prop manipulation are judged because of
this the fewer characteristics a props
core vocabulary of movement shares with
toss juggling the less skillful artistic
and disciplined it's seen as and to be
clear I don't think that any of this is
a malicious conscious or even deliberate
process I think it inevitably follows
from the practice of making one specific
kind of prop manipulation the default
and I see many many real world
consequences of this for one
PO is deeply unpopular in the juggling
world the top 40 jugglers list has been
a project maintained now for 21 years by
the aforementioned Luke burd in that
time despite a plethora of jugglers
online insisting that jugglers have
always thought of Po as a type of
juggling only two artists who use poy
have ever been featured on the list both
of whom won their spots by juggling
rather than by spinning their poy the
international juggling Association
arguably one of the most important
International bodies for promoting and
educating the general public on the
history of juggling has had only a
single article that I can find in the
past 5 years specifically on PO spinning
and that article was riddled with
misinformation and wild extrapolations
from spotty data they have also included
several spotlights for people who juggle
their POI but appear not to have
featured anyone who Embraces any other
technique for POI how is it that in a
community that professes to have always
thought of Po as a type of juggling that
artists like Nick woy Rona mclin or UDA
imamura po Spinners that by any
objective measure are some of the
greatest artists to practice the art
form have never been featured on either
the top 40 jugglers list or on the 's
website and this attitude doesn't end
there the few po Spinners and other flow
artists I've seen go to ATT 10 circus
school have all had one thing in common
they come out of it abandoning their
original prop they're pushed into toss
juggling and acrobatics and I think the
reason is pretty simple the circus world
has had had formal curricula in place
for disciplines it recognizes
artistically rather than expand to
create curricula for other disciplines
however it's simply easier to squeeze
artists from those other disciplines
into the boxes that they already
recognize the implication has been clear
to both me and other po Spinners now for
more than a decade you are neither seen
nor respected in the juggling Community
unless you place yourself in proximity
closer to toss juggling that attitude
isn't just implicit either it's been
made explicit countless times both in
personal conversations as well as in
public discourse time and you have this
PO but even then you can say well yeah
the PO is a cross between the ball and
the club I don't really see the yeah
maybe X Factor and time it's not what
I'm doing basically it's just I'm doing
juggling it's too small for me it's just
juggling is bigger and time again we're
Club juggers of course it's better than
po POI is the object of ridicule whether
it's juggers joking did everyone just
get tricked into loving po being
harassed for expressing an appreciation
for
poy or simply being barred from
positions of visibility and respect this
sort of intimidation and gatekeeping has
been present for years and honestly it
does make sense in the taxonomy jugglers
have created for their art if I was
judging POI by the standards of juggling
I would probably find it lacking too so
when we set the standards by which po
should be judged as being centered in
the juggling world that doesn't create a
space that is inclusive to us it creates
a space in which we have to assimilate
to receive respect this is the piece of
the puzzle that makes me the most upset
because over time I've gradually seen
more and more pois Spinners internalize
this sense of inferiority rather than
explore and expand on the art form as
we've known it for decades they're told
they're not creating art on a high
enough level they're told that the world
they inhabit is too small and that
juggling is the real valid and more
historically established art the irony
being that it's actually the juggling
world that is small and narrow because
rather than expanding to include the
features of additional disciplines it
instead has to squeeze us into a really
specific box to include us at all and
regardless of how you try to define the
word juggling I don't think that
attempts to assimilate po into it have
been positive for our community overall
during the Heyday of the tech po boom in
the late 2000s and early 2010s new
Frameworks and works of scholarship on
PO movement dropped with Dependable
regularity since manipulation has risen
to become the dominant style however
this Focus has switched instead to
adapting tricks already pioneered in the
juggling world to poy that may mean that
people are the first to perform a given
trick but it doesn't mean that the trick
is an original work I think we've seen a
decline in originality and creativity in
the PO world as a result of a similation
into juggling and I think we've seen an
alarming number of both new and old
artists intern aliz their position of
prop manipulation hierarchy as being
beneath that of jugglers and either
switch props to climb to a higher rank
of the hierarchy or simply accept the
microaggressions that come along with
being near the bottom and yes
doubtlessly if you're watching this
video and you're a Levi Wan spinner
fiber Whip artist Glover glow Stringer
or any of the countless other prop
disciplines that PO Spinners have
historically looked down upon and said
first time you know what good point we
absolutely do this stuff too it's not
right when jugglers do it to us and it's
not right when po Spinners do it to you
either I would also be remiss if I
didn't point out that this meme of prop
manipulation hierarchy was also
something that was already present in
the POI Community even before
manipulation took off as a style the
whole Tech versus flow debate has its
roots in the ways that Tech po Spinners
have acted as Gatekeepers towards people
who focused more on movement than on
building out their trick skill trees we
already were not great at this and
assimilation has dialed this problem up
to 11 so if indeed the Merit of
assimilating into the juggling world is
dubious for pois Spinners It does bear
asking why do so many jugglers and even
some po Spinners want to do it anyway
what do they get out of this Arrangement
and what's wrong with po Spinners
viewing ourselves as an independent art
form the answer I think in all honesty
is that they kind of need us and I think
that's a fact the juggling world is
having a really really difficult time
processing
part four who's
wagon so I want to jump back real
quickly to the story that I opened this
whole tretis on while I'm sure that the
argument my juggler friend advanced was
one that existed before that discussion
I had never encountered it in my travels
or interactions with jugglers before
that and it stuck out to me not just
because it seemed to sideline my
original question but also because it
felt strangely like somebody trying to
prze to me and I don't think that the
timing of it was a coincidence 2013 was
a very very important year in the flow
Arts that was the year that the number
of flow festivals peaked out at 50 we
had an average of one per week that year
and most weeks you'd actually have a
choice between multiple festivals being
run in different parts of the
[Music]
country and it was also right after i'
posted the first ever top 10 po Spinners
list to my YouTube channel which though
controversial was enormously popular
I'll be the first to admit that I copied
the vast majority of the format from
Luke bur's top 40 jugglers list and in
hindsight it might have been a good idea
for me to hit him up and ask him before
I copied his process and
format but there was also something that
really stuck out to me and I'm willing
to bet stuck out to other people about
our two lists that year Luke published
his results as multiple videos rather
than a single video compilation that
year so it's hard to run a direct
comparison
but of those videos the one with the
most views is just below
5,000 the top 10 po Spinners list from
the same year though it currently sits
at more than 200,000 in other words in
2013 pois spinning and flowarts were
wildly popular both in person and online
but things were perhaps not as rosy in
the circus World by the end of the
decade Ringling Brothers Big Apple
Circus and circus lay three of the
biggest circus companies in the world
had all declared bankruptcy granted
they've all reemerged since but in each
case it's only the result of being
heavily subsidized by philanthropic
interests attendance has not recovered
in the intervening years what's more by
2013 a decline in attendance to the ejc
from its peak in 2011 had already begun
by the close of the decade that
attendance had dropped more than 9% from
the decade previous and granted this
next point is more anecdotal rather than
data driven but I can remember around
2013 having conversations with friends
who were not in either the flow or
juggling World about this debate and I
was kind of surprised to find that
juggling and circus had kind of a brand
problem the people I talked to thought
of circus and juggling as being more
oriented for Children's Entertainment
and though few knew exactly what flow
Arts actually meant the inclusion of the
word arts in the title suggested
something that rang intriguingly high
brow so at this point you can probably
see where this is leading boy and flow
Arts were on a boom of creative output
and cultural relevance while the
momentum for circus was headed a little
bit in the opposite direction side note
I know I'm using circus and juggling
more or less interchangeably in this
section and that has more to do with it
being difficult to find solid metrics
for the popularity of juggling at the
time but it also does have to be said
that they were frequently positioned
synonymously to me in discussions with
jugglers at the time if you want to take
that as a gap in my reasoning I
certainly don't blame you but show me
the data that disproves my case so what
do you do when you're facing existential
threats and you see another art that's
arguably pretty similar On The Rise
seems like a great time to hit your ride
on that wagon or perhaps convince them
to hit your ride on your wagon because
after all the props that sit at the
bottom of the hierarchy aren't going to
be the ones that drive the ship now are
they po Spinners and flow artists looked
at the degree of respect conferred to
jugglers and circus performers in many
parts of the world and thought to place
themselves within an already established
and respected art form and more
specifically Tech po Spinners looked to
numbers juggling as a subculture and saw
a lot of similarities in terms of skill
trees an emphasis on virtuosity at the
expense of presentation and friendly
competition so what if the price was
taking a lower spot on the social ladder
that just meant you had to pick up a
whole bunch of challenging new tricks to
fit in for jugglers folding in po
Spinners and flow artists potentially
meant a boost in attendance for juggling
events and more people buying juggling
equipment it also didn't hurt that it
gave them the chance to put those
scruffy upstart American flow artists
back in their place the irony being that
in the long run I don't think that this
strategy actually worked out for either
party for one thing we didn't know it at
the time but the boom and flow festivals
turned out to be a bubble that collapsed
within a couple years event attendance
dropped and there was a huge amount of
generational turnover with many of the
big stars of the early 2010s leaving the
seen by the middle of the decade and
while promoting the idea of Po being a
part of juggling seemed and continues to
seem very inclusive to many jugglers the
reality is that we just haven't shown up
to boost the attendance to a lot of
circus events personally I think it's
because there was always a cultural gap
between jugglers and po Spinners and
because juggling meetups Center toss
juggling so completely they only managed
to capture a limited percentage of Po
Spinners while many others simply return
to their flow events in the woods or
fell out of the scene entirely there's
this old joke in the business world that
when you merge together two failing
companies you rarely get a successful
company out of the deal you wind up with
a much bigger failing company that's now
also much harder to run over the summer
of 2023 there was a post in a Facebook
group called circad demics by a young
woman looking for input on a project she
was working on regarding the taxonomy of
juggling in her first draft it was
pretty clear that she knew nearly
nothing about flow arts for example she
placed Rope Dart as a subset of poi
though I didn't and still don't believe
that PO spinning is a part of juggling I
at least felt an imperative to help her
understand the flow Arts World a little
better and threw out several suggestions
on how she could update this part of her
organizational chart she took a lot of
that feedback and integrated it into
future revisions and though I could
still see some inaccuracies it was at
least a huge Improvement so imagine my
surprise when a couple months later she
releases copies of the chart as a paid
product bear in mind she at no point in
her posts on this project said that she
was creating something that she was
going to sell and nowhere on her poster
does it credit myself or any of the
other people who gave her feedback and
corrected her mistakes our work was
simply used to give the veneer of a more
refined and more inclusive product if
there is a better metaphor for the
relationship between the juggling and
poy World currently I'm not sure what it
is part five the mauy of it all
so there is one other aspect of this
that I haven't talked about yet and
lacking another spot to place it I'm
just going to stick it awkwardly close
to the end and that's in our discussion
around the relationship between Po and
juggling we haven't mentioned the true
roots of poi at all namely do mauy
people think that PO is a form of
juggling do they think that their art
fits under this umbrella I'll be candid
that I think the topic probably deserves
an entire video unto itself and that
it's a difficult question to answer
because sources are more than a little
spotty but I have found one that I think
provides at least some answers that I
think are relevant in her incredibly
detailed 2004 paper on the history of
poi Karen penai identifies several games
played in different Polynesian
Traditions that almost certainly
represent ancestral practices from which
po evolved and all of them fit clearly
into a framework that she herself
identifies as being a Polynesian form of
juggling examples include hio hoo
AA and the antecedent to poy known as P
or P crucially however perangai
identifies a point in which there is a
split from this juggling tradition
toward placing po more firmly in the
dance or kapahaka Camp again this is a
question that I think should probably be
explored more deeply in another video
but I do just want to stick a pin in it
because one point I've seen made about
POI with regards to how it relates to
juggling is a lack of respect shown to
our lineage and you know what there's
absolutely a valid point there but I
think that lineage passes through mouy
hands rather than those of Western
jugglers and yes we absolutely should
respect and explore it more is there
potentially a tension in arguing about
being assimilated into the juggling
World in an art form that arguably has
been appropriated in many ways from an
entirely different tradition yeah there
almost certainly is okay so at this
point we've haggled over semantics we've
talked about why putting po into the
juggling world in itself creates a
hierarchy we've also talked about part
of what I think is motivating the
attempts to merge the Two Worlds and how
the direct antecedent tooy fits into all
of this so how about we talk about what
we do with this information is there a
way to resolve these
differences part six a little
respect hard as it may be to believe my
agenda here is not to so Discord I
honestly think that that already exists
and I'm simply outlining why but it does
beg an obvious question is there a way
forward in which both jugglers and pois
Spinners can coexist and honestly I
think the answer is yes but it's going
to take some work one of the biggest
pieces of push back I'm anticipating
from this video is going to be people
accusing me of creating Division and I
think it's important to note that I
don't think that acknowledging
differences inherently leads to conflict
we can see respect and celebrate
differences without those differences
becoming a source of conflict unless we
choose to make them a source of conflict
the flip side of this of course is that
if a person sees acknowledging
differences as inherently leading to
division or conflict that it seems to
also kind of imply that they don't see a
way to peacefully coexist without those
differences being removed or hidden in
other words that others become more like
them and for the record I've had plenty
of great interactions with jugglers over
the years and shared space with many of
them and plan to continue doing so in
the future my problem is not with
individual jugglers but with the culture
around it that many participate in
whether they know it or not and because
of that I don't think that me or even
the majority of Po Spinners are going to
truly feel comfortable or even welcome
in spaces that jugglers have created
given the status quo one of the biggest
and most important things that needs to
be resolved is that we need to
acknowledge that trying to assimilate po
Spinners by reframing juggling as being
a more Universal concept is not in
itself an inclusive
act jugglers need to acknowledge that
the way that they have framed the
concept of juggling has centered
themselves and in doing so created a
hierarchy that places other props in a
place of inferiority the message is both
implicit and explicit within juggling
spaces even many of my well-intentioned
juggler friends frequently just refuse
to acknowledge that pois Spinners
receive microaggressions and abuse from
jugglers and I get why they benefit from
being part of the system as it is when
you're part of an art form that centers
you in it it's easy to miss that fact
because you're not the one who's on the
receiving end of the jokes or harassment
but whether you want to believe it or
not it is there and it's very real so
let me be clear neither I nor anyone
else has to learn to juggle to become a
real artist the second thing I really
think is necessary is genuine curiosity
ask po Spinners about what they do about
what they want to see in an event a PO
spinner isn't simply a juggler waiting
to happen they're unique and valid art s
already don't understand how that art
works that totally makes sense ask us
what we love about POI and hear the
answers even if they feel unfamiliar and
honestly this next note is more of a
general one but all of us in the flow
and circus worlds really have to
dismantle our egos someone having fun
with the only three tricks they know
does not make us ourselves less of an
artist or the art we practice any less
valid the shadow work here is that I
think many of us are afraid that we
won't be taken seriously if there are
people people out there that do just
engage in this stuff casually or just
for fun the art can be fun and also the
work you do with it worthy of being
taken seriously both can be true at the
same time let me also be clear if you
spend Po and you consider yourself a
juggler that's great if that's where you
find your inspiration and a sense of
blogging then I'm glad to hear it I do
not think any less of you for labeling
yourself in a way that makes you feel
seen but I am not nor have I ever been a
juggler so when jugglers roll up on me
and tell me I don't understand the
historical context of the term or that
juggling is really the platonic concept
for all object manipulation they don't
sound to me like they're trying to be
inclusive they sound paternalistic that
doesn't come from a place of welcoming
it asserts ownership without having to
understand the art on its own terms you
want to show po Spinners and other flow
artists that we are actually respected
in the juggling Community prove it vote
us onto the top 40 juggers list write
articles about us on the IGA website
make sure po Spinners not just po
jugglers but po Spinners appear in The
Gallows of juggling festivals and not
just Open Stage invite us there do the
work to make us feel welcome make sure
that we appear in places of honor and
respect and if that sounds like an
impossible or impertinent demand well it
kind of seems like you agree with me
that juggler showing po Spinners respect
is too big a flexx what was that about
inclusivity again
also just because social media is what
it is I just have to make it clear that
this is not an open invitation to harass
any of the jugglers that I've mentioned
here nor any jugglers in general Justice
here isn't going out to harass jugglers
the way many of them have harassed po
Spinners over the years Justice is that
harassment ending entirely we don't need
an eye for an eye here it's enough that
we create spaces for ourselves where we
can celebrate our art on our own terms
and finally here's my message to other
po Spinners our art is awesome if others
can't recognize what makes us unique in
the prop manipulation world then that's
their loss but it also does come with
some responsibility we shouldn't be
trying to beg for a ticket to someone
else's party just so we can feel like
we're actually real artists We should
strive to create real art on our own
terms that's hard and it takes a really
long time it requires us to go through
the process of selecting what we like
and what we don't it requires us to
develop our own theories of performance
Aesthetics and expression for our art it
requires us to find our own forms of
discipline and share them with the rest
of the world it's really really hard
work but I think that it's worth it in
the end to create things that stand the
test of time and with that I think I'm
finally done have fun with your friends
there's no reason not to but also don't
put up with people that make you feel
small you do not have to be this tall to
get on this ride what are your thoughts
on all this how do you identify is there
a way of framing this that I haven't
thought of that's really important leave
me a comment and let me
[Music]
know oh my goodness that was a lot all
told I think this video took somewhere
around six months to write and produce
and went through so many drafts doing
all that work would never have been
possible without the backing of my
supporters on patreon in particular I
want to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now writing out massive video essays
like this would be absolutely impossible
without those patreon supporters so if
you'd like to see more of them please
sign up to support my work over at
patreon.com Factor poy please and thank
you in advance and hey if you like this
video you might like the video essay I
did on why the flow Arts never went
mainstream I'll go ahead and leave a
link on screen to that as well as down
in the description thank you so much for
watching get out to flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace